Sa nay người mình xin thằng xin năm 2018, đây thứ 15 tăng quan,
vì viên bộ chính trị, bộ trường bộ công an đặt khi cứ định truy thằng cấp bật hàng bởi vậy đồng xin với đồng cánh
công an xa rồi lập tình đặc lắc khi xin trong khi làm gì buồn.
Theo đó, bộ trường lượng tăng quan đặt khi cứ định truy thằng cấp bật hàng từ thiệu tài lên chúng ta trước thời hà
kể từ ngày 13 thằng xin năm 2018, bởi vậy đồng xin với đồng cánh,
xin năm 2019, tảm cái chiến, quế quan, xa rồi lập tình đặc lắc,
kể giá viên chúng cấp, cắn bộ công an xa rồi lập tình đặc lắc.
Các bạn có định về việc hỗ trợ số tiền một trong trợ đồng chức từ quyến nghĩa tình đồng bộ công an như dần đối với ra định đồng xin với đồng cánh.
Trước đó, người mình tạm thằng xin năm 2018,
công an tình đặc lắc thông tin bà đồng về vụ việc đồng xin với đồng cánh bị tấn công khi xin khi làm gì buồn.
Cô thề, sáng cùng an, công an xa rồi lập nhận được tin báo của người dân về việc tối với thằng xin năm 2018,
với văn tì, xin năm 2019, mùa xa rồi lập có hình viết của ý về thương việc đối với xin với thiết,
chiến dấu tì, sống cùng nhà.
Sau khi sắp mình, công an xa rồi lập đã lập tổ công tác của năm cán bộ,
chiến sĩ xuống địa bản địa mời tì về chủ sở làm việc.
Để khoảng 18,5 cung ngày khi thời tổ công tác tiếp cận gần nhà,
tì bỏ trẻ tới hút được dân kéo thuộc thuộc tôn bốn xa rồi lập.
Cô chiến tổ công tác chuyên đối tượng đồng xin với đồng cánh bị tì giúp dò trộ trạc hiện đồng xin khi xin.
Để khoảng 12 giờ 1 mũ mũ mũ mũ mũ mũ, lực lượng công an đã bác sửa tìa tại nhà dây.
Tại các quan công an, bước đầu ti đá hành hành vi của mình,
các quan kể rất đều trạc công an tình đặc lắp đã ra quy định tạm sữa hình sự mũi văn tì để làm só vụ việc.
Ông đề đồng quân, chú tịch i bán dân xa rồi lập, cho biết ra định an cạnh chưa đầy khu chú tại thu mà, xa rồi hành,
xa rồi hành, xa khi xáp nhập để giới hành chính, để phương này đổi thành thu mà xa rồi lập.
2 vụ trong an cạnh đã có một châu trai bụt tùy.
Bộ an đang mang thay ở thằng tử tám và làm lời trợ tới nhà, ông quân chỉ sẻ.
Sự ra đi đường của của an để lại nối đau qua lớn và gánh nặng cho vợ cùng con chai nhỏ, khi chau vẫn còn nữ ngác trở bú trở về.